I guess you studies you get there not
all of you are at the end but that's
okay I think it's time to observe what
did you get for the first one you should
use to be able to state it you shouldn't
need to have done in the expansion it's
a squared minus B squared a squared
minus B squared
it's the difference of squares right
what at this one this is difference of
cubes is it a cubed minus b cubed and
then hopefully you got suspicious and
your algebraic sort of manipulation
confirmed your suspicions this is going
to be a to the 4 a to the 4 minus B to
the power 4 ok so these three results
here they're all three examples of what
we would call difference of powers
difference of squares is what you get
first difference of cubes comes next and
then difference of fours difference of
tesseracts I don't know we don't have a
name for that so when we think about
this I want us to try and make a
conjecture as to the pattern that you
see here and to see if we can generalize
this and you'll see why I'm going to try
and do this because of this end target
that I'm heading toward right I'm
setting up so I can deal with this thing
okay so if we've got a cubed sorry a
squared minus B squared a cubed minus b
cubed a to the four minus B to the four
what I want to ask all of you is what do
you think this might look like if this
were something we can factorize right
what might it look like after it is
factorize now don't give me the holiday
talk how do you reckon we might start
this thing yes right hey
are you excited with the nays a good
idea anyone want to advance on a have a
look have a look at the happen right
what's the thing that keeps on coming up
every single time I've got it I've got
at the front of each of these right I've
just gotten a minus B every time okay
I'm just gonna write that that's a good
start it seems to be happening every
time and then the next thing that
happens is I open up my brackets and
then let's think carefully what do you
think the first term should be I am
gonna write an A but have a look at what
the first term is here it's not just a
by itself that term it seems to grow
doesn't it hmm
what do you think exactly hmm let's
think about this for a second okay I'll
come back to you in a second this thing
is a squared minus B squared and there's
an eight of them one at the front there
yeah this is a cubed minus b cubed and
there's an a squared there sound all
right
and then lastly you've got a to the 4
motor speed before and then this first
term is 3 in other words it's always 1
less than your difference of squares
difference of cubes difference of powers
of 4 right so here I've got difference
of the powers of n so if I want
something just 1 less than that this
would be n minus 1 just 1 less than
whatever you started with over there
okay rastan what do you see next hold on
hold there so this is a plus B to the
power of 1 is that what you're saying
yeah yeah I can't so have a look at this
thing so you just said a plus B to the
power of 2 but let's just hold that
thought for a second because I don't
know that a plus B to the power of 2 I
don't know that it actually is equal to
this is it what's missing it's so very
close I'm missing a 2 right if they are
a 2 in here then it would be equal right
but in fact there isn't a 2 and there
are coefficients in here either or the
coefficients are all just one okay so
it's very close to a plus B or square
it's a very common error in fact okay
but it's a little bit off what are we
going to get next what happens to the
A's and the B's as I progress from one
term to the next in that second set of
brackets what happens the A's let's just
think about the A's
I went from for example from here I went
from a cube to a squared so I get one
less a what about here a squared goes to
a yeah it's a de perón is it it's just
one less so how would I write one less a
than that very good n minus 2 it's like
whatever this thing is take away 1 and
then you'll get to the next one right so
that's a to the power of n minus 2 but
then that's not the only thing something
else hangs on for the ride what else
appears yeah just a single bee just one
there it is there and there it is there
okay so I'm trying to establish a
pattern here right cuz this is a bit
this is a bit more vague in general but
I think we're almost there right as you
keep on hopping along that second pair
of brackets right what happens to the
age they keep on drop me down by one
every time right so if I had n minus one
in the no minus 2 what will the next one
be n minus 3 very good drops down by one
more and then what happens to these
they're not dropping down the bees are
going up aren't there so I have no bees
here I've got one here how many bees
will I have here I have two of them B
squared right okay so at this point I
feel like I could keep on writing this
obviously but I think we've got the
patent here the A's are going down the
bees are going up eventually you get to
some point have a look at the last term
along the end right you get to some
point where how many aids are left on
that very last term there are no mores
left right they've all shrunk down and
all disappeared and then the last thing
you have is just some number of beings
right how many of them mmm look really
carefully right notice here I end with a
B squared just like I started with an a
squared yeah over here I end with a b
cubed just like i started with in a
cubed right
in other words these two powers here
they match don't they they pout the
powers match on the end so therefore my
final term is B ^ yeah just like I had a
2-1 I'm gonna end with B to the N minus
1 so far so good okay now I know that
might seem like a real universe away
from what we're dealing with but I'm
trying to set this up we're gonna need
this piece in a little bit okay so have
that written down and then file it away
and now underneath that what I'd like
you to draw three places two little
Cartesian planes just give me the first
quadrant and we're going to remember
something from last week when we
introduced calculus and then we're going
to expand it we're going to push on it a
little bit okay
senia are we finished with trig for now
Zaki is right we are never finished with
you but for now we've hit pause on it
okay okay so here are some Cartesian
planes and I've just put the same graph
on each one now we're starting to get
back towards calculus we're setting up
the we're setting up the scene here I
want us to remember when we were
differentiating for the first time we
introduced this thing called the
difference quotient do you remember this
the difference question it was just a
way of calculating gradient on this
thing but it was a particular kind of
gradient it was a gradient from X and
then we went forward a little bit does
anyone remember what the little bit was
how far over your forward it was H right
so this next bit was X plus h this
ringing your bell
yes so this here this is the Run which
is the denominator of the difference
question and you got this part here
which is the rise now how do we work out
the rise where do we get these Y values
from they don't remember if this is like
f of X or something like that
oh this y-coordinate pain if you put an
X you're just gonna get well then why in
this case would be f of X right what
about the one up here f of X plus h
because that is the corresponding
horizontal coordinate so you put it in
right
so hopefully you remember that on the
basis of this we introduced this this F
- this derivative right as the limit for
this difference question we said this if
your H your gap here gets teeny teeny
tiny right and then you stick in the
difference question here this is like
working out the gradient of a tangent
not a secant remember that it's like
taking these two points and should make
it a little more obvious for you taking
these two points and bringing them
together does this make sense okay
hopefully it's ringing about now what I
want to try and get across to you here
and it's the next piece of the puzzle
with this and then we're ready to go to
actually do this proof isn't this is not
the only way just state the derivative
it's not the only way I can set this up
so
looks a little bit different if I take
the same two points okay and I'm going
to call and get them in this order I'm
gonna make this right one X you'll see
why a bit later on and I'm gonna just
call this other value just a different
number I'm not gonna say it's like it's
plus or X minus or something like that
I'm just going to call it see that's
just a convention okay
I'm again going to try and state the
derivative in terms of this difference
question its business right but this
time I'm gonna have a different run
aren't i there's no H to be seen can
anyone tell me what would that
horizontal distance the run be in this
case hmm
think carefully how did I work out H
here where does that come from
well it's the further further to the
right take away the one to the left
right that value take away that now for
example it could have been five take
away four which would be one right or
like three and a half take away 3 which
would be half so in other words it's
this guy which is the bigger value take
away this guy with just a small though
yes right so it's X minus C let's write
that in that's going to be outrun okay
now I'll rise let's think about this guy
as well I need some Y values to go with
this just like this
all right so let's have a look we'll do
this one first what should the Y value
of that guy be remember yeah both of
these are FX right y equals f of X so
for this value I'm just putting in X so
I'm going to get f of X up here what
this one
very good so whatever horizontal
coordinate I just put that into the
function notation and you'll get a value
about f of C so what will the rise be in
this case you know how we did on this
value take away this right the bigger
one take away the smaller one yeah very
good here's the bigger value and here's
the smaller one so I'll take away from
the bigger value I will take away the
smaller one so far so good
okay so I'm going to do the same thing
here but there's gonna be a subtle
difference when I
right my derivative down here same thing
F dash X but when I write my limit right
there's no H do you see that it's no H
to be found so my limits gonna look a
little bit different I don't have a H
that's going towards your a pay close
attention I don't have an H that's going
to zero what I have is a letter C that I
want to get toward X like that's the
same thing right I'm taking these two
points and I'm sort of squishing them
together right so instead of writing H
goes towards zero what I'm gonna write
is C goes toward X they mean the same
thing just take those two points which
currently look separate and see what
happens as they get closer and closer
together is that okay are you right with
me right okay now what will the
difference question look like in this
case it's still going to be a fraction
cuts a question but my rise and run
these are these things that I worked out
here right so here's my numerator f of X
take away F of C what's my denominator X
minus C very good okay what a big box
around this guy because this result
alongside this one here they're going to
be our keys for unlocking for actually
proving this thing that we started with
okay one last question before we go eyes
up again this is difference of squares a
squared minus B squared how many terms
it's a non rhetorical question how many
terms are in that second set of brackets
there are two terms out there you're
like well here hello it's hard right
okay I ask you another question how many
terms this is a cubed minus b cubed how
many terms are in here just just in just
in this set of brackets just three right
one two three
last one and a power of four minus B the
power for when you factorize how many
terms are here for two terms three terms
four times okay good